we're here two more institutions that
are under fervent attack in this country
the Second Amendment and an objective
press this week CNN received something
called a Cronkite award you didn't win
but they did and they won for a
full-blown propaganda event that they
staged after last year's parkland
shooting it was a town hall on gun
violence it was a transparent excuse to
ambush anyone who supports the Second
Amendment and denounced them on national
television which is what happened I
think what you're asking about is the
assault weapons ban yes sir so let me be
honest with you about that one if I
believed that that law would have
prevented this from happening I would
support it but I want to explain to you
why it would not can you tell me right
now that you will not accept a single
donation from the NRA
I wish the NRA lady I could have talked
to because I would ask her how she can
look in the mirror considering the fact
that she has children let me answer the
question let me answer the question you
can shout me down when I'm finished but
let me answer in this question I would
have done everything in my power to
prevent that
you just told this group of people that
you are standing up for them you're not
standing up for them such demagogues CNN
did that dinner lashes a spokesman for
the NRA she was at that townhall you
just saw the tape and she joins us
tonight it's it's upsetting to watch
that tape because it is so unfair it's a
mob basically screaming at you what was
it like to be there well Chuck our
thanks for talking about this well we've
learned so many things since that time
right especially with Scott Ezreal on
that stage I don't know how to describe
it i when we found out that the Town
Hall was taking place that I believe it
was on a Wednesday I found out that I
was going there Tuesday I found out that
I was going to be asked questions that
afternoon while on the plane and it
wasn't until I got there that I found
out that I was going to be on stage and
then later on stage with Scott Israel
and they actually queued me to walk out
into the arena to a black-eyed peas song
and that some of the footage that's
after after the cameras stopped rolling
with CNN what CNN didn't tell people is
that they allowed and invited
politicians to come up on stage and
election year Scott Israel was able to
make a big oh electioneering speech
before this even began in which he
already started deflecting blame by
putting it on me it was treated as this
I think right for ratings they tried to
stylize this to make it most emotionally
impactful I questioned the ethics of
them putting it on this way this wasn't
tucker this wasn't a journalistic
endeavor they had this townhall
literally titled it was called stand up
the students of Marjory Stoneman Douglas
demand action that's not a journalistic
endeavor that is not a journalistic
enterprise that's advocacy why wouldn't
question the ethics this is flat-out
unethical it's wrong I can't imagine why
they'd win whatever dumb award they won
they should be ashamed of what they did
well I mean people were really hostile
toward you how did you feel what was
that quite I've never been in a
situation like that I've never been in a
situation where I had someone rush me
from behind and tried to get me and a
member of my detail grabbed them I mean
I showed up in good faith to have a
discussion about the issue at hand and
it wasn't just this Town Hall either I
mean you'll remember Tucker even after
this that particular Network allowed to
stand unchallenged on their airwaves
accusations about not just my integrity
as a person and as a mother but also
millions of law-abiding gun owners all
across the United States their integrity
was questioned their parental genuine
genuine s was questioned they were
questioned as seeing people simply
because they thought differently what
they did what this town hall did was set
dialogue back by I don't know how how
much it pushed dialogue back it was an
embarrassing display of bias and they
should feel ashamed instead of back
patting themselves for this I mean
honestly one last thing Tucker this for
them to say that this advanced the
national conversation on gun control is
like saying the Salem witch trials
advanced the conversation on on women's
rights that's exactly what this was like
it was an embarrassment they should be
ashamed and to do this just days after a
mass murder to leverage that tragedy the
way they did they should be ashamed I
agree with you a hundred percent thanks
very much for telling us what that was
like
it's disgusting